I was speaking to the government
Minister earlier good morning to you
um she said that the government doesn't
comment on Market movements that's fair
enough isn't it
well of course the chief secretary to
the treasury Crystal did comment on
Market movements on Friday and he said
that financial markets were welcoming
what um the chancellor did so it seems
that they are happy to comment when they
think things are going well and less
happy to comment uh when things are
going less well what we need to hear
from the government is a credible plan
for the public finances and a an in a
credible plan to grow the economy and it
is because we got neither of those on
Friday that markets have reacted in the
way that they have both on Friday and
look I think that many people hoped that
over the weekend and as we got on to
Monday trading that things would
stabilize that hasn't happened so far
and the pound is now at an all-time low
against the dollar that is very
concerning because what it means is that
the things that are priced in in dollars
gas and oil but also other things will
go up in price adding to the
inflationary pressures and the pressure
on the cost of living here in the UK but
it's also pushing up government
borrowing costs which means more
government spending will go in servicing
the debt and that will in turn mean
higher borrowing costs for ordinary
families in Britain through their
mortgage rates and elsewhere so this is
a serious situation A Cause for concern
I started my career at the bank of
England and I've got to say I have never
seen anything like this before and the
chancellor instead of doubling down at
the weekend on his position on on Friday
uh needs to Now set out credible plans
um yeah but there are kids parts of the
budget aren't there that you agree with
such as the uh reversal of the National
Insurance increase and the cutting the
basic rate of income tax it must be
pretty tricky being uh the party in
opposition when there are uh strong
storm uh Busters like that that people
really uh welcome
we support of course support for
ordinary working people those people on
Modest and middle incomes you'll
remember that uh we oppose the increase
in National Insurance contributions when
it was first uh proposed we voted
against it and we said that when it came
in in April it was the wrong tax at the
wrong time Liz truss and quasiquoting
voted for those increases in National
Insurance that they are now rightly uh
reversing and for similar reasons we
support the cut in the basic rate
attacks from 20p to 19p because the
truth is ordinary working people on
Modest and middle incomes are struggling
at the moment with the rising costs of
energy with the rising costs of the food
shop and wages not keeping up and so
while we support those measures the
targeted measures to help people on
those modest and middle incomes I do
oppose the cuts in taxes for the very
wealthiest in society I think it is
grossly unfair to be cutting taxes for
people earning more than 150 000 pounds
a year a tax cut that means that
somebody earning a million pounds a year
would get 50 000 pounds every year uh in
lower taxes at a time when it is people
at the bottom and in the middle who are
struggling most with the rising cost of
living this idea that trickle-down
economics that somehow giving more to
people at the top is going to help
everybody else hasn't worked in the past
I don't believe it will work today I did
put that to the minister made the point
that it was
um 53 000 pounds was 53 years of
Universal Credit uh uplift which the
government has taken away she didn't
accept that as an argument but National
Insurance
um that that cart which you support
where will the money come from if and
when you're in government for the NHS
because that's what it was supposed to
be used for
well I listened to what the chancellor
said in the statement on Friday and he
said very clearly that it wouldn't
affect the money that was going into the
National Health Service and that's what
we've said all along
um that the National Health Service
should be uh funded but not through not
on the backs of higher taxes on ordinary
working people I want a fair attack
system that's why for example I've said
that there should be an extension of the
windfall tax on the enormous profits
that energy Giants are making at the
moment because right now we've got a
situation where because of Putin's war
on Ukraine everybody is facing higher
energy bills but the energy Giants are
making unimaginable profits and the
government are leaving that on the table
putting all of the costs of their energy
package on current and future taxpayers
that is not the right approach when we
have already got so much government debt
and so much government borrowing we need
to put our public finances on a
sustainable footing but we also need our
Public Services on a sustainable footing
because economic growth also requires
having young people leaving school and
college with the skills needed for the
world of work it requires having doctors
and nurses keeping people fit and well
so that they can work and we've seen in
the last few years people drop out of
the labor market because of illness and
long-term conditions and so further cuts
to our health and our education budgets
we would oppose because you need strong
public services for a growing economy
too you brought up energy bills there
the government says that it's capped at
two and a half thousand pounds for two
years from what we've heard from you
guys you're only talking about help for
six months what would you do after that
if you were in power
we set out a package of measures before
the government had measures for any
period of time we set that out in August
because we felt that energy customers
needed to have that reassurance that
that help was coming and it would have
come under
um a labor government sooner
um we set out a six-month fully funded
and fully costed
um uh package and we said that more
might be needed and we would look at the
situation in April we welcome the fact
that the government has now acted we
support the the package they've put in
place the dividing line now though is
who pays for that package of measures
because under the government's proposals
it is current and future taxpayers that
will have to pay back
um this money in the years to come while
under Labor's proposals we would have
extended the windfall tax on those big
profits being made by the energy Giants
rather than putting all of this on more
borrowing and more debt that in the end
has to be paid back so just to clarify
um you support the governments to year
cap at two and a half thousand pounds on
energy bills
we think there should be there should be
a freeze in energy bills that was our
proposal not an increase in the capital
freeze we also said
No so at the moment prices are 1971
pounds on average per year we would have
Frozen bills at that level rather than
allowing them to go to two and a half a
thousand pounds and we also said that
people on prepayment meters shouldn't be
paying a premium
um when they are some usually some of
the poorest people in society but we do
support the energy package we would do a
little bit more on that front as I've
said but the big dividing line on this
is about who pays for it and under labor
we would ask the energy Giants to make
more of a contribution not just whacking
it on government borrowing and
government debt Dockers are on strike in
Liverpool at the moment on Friday the
chance to announce plans to diminish the
powers of unions to be able to strike
what do you think
that the best thing that labor can do to
help striking workers is to get a labor
government and I understand why working
people are taking industrial action
they're seeing their wages not increase
with the rising cost of living they're
seeing inflation spiral out of control
and they're worried about how their
families are going to get through the
next few months when their wages aren't
keeping up with the rising cost of
living it's why we need to get a grip of
inflation and the bonfire of workers
rights and the uh the the greater
restrictions on trade unions right to
organize that is not the right way to
deal with this the right way to deal
with this is to sit down with trade
unions and working people and work out
what is a fair and affordable deal we
didn't have industrial action like this
when labor was lost in government
because we treated working people with
respect that this government seems to
want to blame working people for the
challenges that we see in our economy at
the moment when the real people to blame
for those challenges is this
conservative government
couple of other thoughts Before I Let
You Go thank you for giving us the time
the rmt chief at Mick Lynch says secure
Starman must cozy up to Working Class
People does that mean you are joining
the dockers on the picket line later on
as I said Kate the best way that the
labor party can support working people
is to get a labor government and that's
why at conference today I'll be setting
out Labor's plans to get good jobs and
investment here in Britain the jobs here
the factories here through investment in
the industries of the future like
electric vehicles offshore wind green
steel hydrogen technology that is the
way to support working people to get a
labor government and after 12 years in
opposition that is what I'm determined
to do
I'm going to set out Labor's I'm not
going to go on the picket line I'm going
to be setting out today on our
conference floor the plans that labor
had to support working people right
across this country that is the way to
help working people to get a labor
government and as I say okay I am sick
of opposition I want to be not the
shadow Chancellor but the chancellor of
the exchequer actually able to fix some
of these problems in our economy today
final thought you're in Andy Burnham's
Manor at the moment of course Northwest
England um says he hasn't ruled out
returning to Westminster would you
support him as labor leader
kisama is the leader of the labor party
my question I'm really proud to serve as
his shadow Chancellor we don't have a
vacancy for leader of the labor party
Kia stammer is leader of the labor party
I've never felt as optimistic about the
future for labor in the 12 and a half
years as I've been an MP as I am today
under Kia's leadership I think that when
people look at the conservatives and the
direction that they are taking us in and
they look at the alternative provided by
labor you'll hear more of that in my
speech today in Kia's speech tomorrow
that laborer winning the Battle of ideas
finally and I um and I am confident that
at the next election we can persuade
people who have left labor in recent
years to come back to labor Andy is a
brilliant mayor and uh and and I work
closely with him but we've got a great
leader of the labor party today in Kia
stamina okay it's good I thought it was
worth asking it's good to talk to you um
I look forward to catching up with you a
bit later on in Liverpool thanks very
much